so we are going to be talking about uh
pandas two poers and duct DB uh which is
a question that I'm getting a lot here
so if you want to follow along
uh
um this there aren't slides per se
everything that I'm going to be talking
about is from a notebook so um if you go
to that link that I shared in in the
resources um that goes to a GitHub page
so
uh and in here you can see is uh let me
bump up the font here um this this is
The Notebook that I'm going to be uh
presenting from today on in my GitHub
and uh one of the cool things about uh
GitHub is that you can come up here to
this code this green button here and if
you click that um there's uh this code
spaces here and you can hit uh plus to
create a code
space what is going to do is going to
fire off a virtual machine on github's
uh infrastructure here and
uh bump up the font so it is launching
vs code here and uh here is The Notebook
right here so don't click on this
notebook if you if you launched the code
space give it a moment it's actually
going to install all the dependencies
here so there you go you can see it's uh
installing the requirements this will
take a moment for this to to run and
then when the when these requirements
are done uh you can click that and it
will open everything up in in Jupiter
and you should be able to follow along
uh from Jupiter right there without
having to do any install or anything on
your end um alternatively this is a
python conference I assume a lot of you
are familiar with installing packages
and whatnot uh there's a requirements
file if you pip install that
requirements file you should be able to
follow along
locally as well okay um awesome so we
got other people from Italy Greece UK uh
Colorado oh hi Mina I'm you're right
around the corner from me and uh moist
door
set United Kingdom awesome
so um I'm excited to like I said I'm
excited to be here excited to answer
questions or concerns that you might
have um I'll try and put uh or try and
uh monitor the chat every now and then
so if you do have a question uh feel
free to use that chat and um Let me let
me answer them okay so um you know back
to back to um GitHub here uh this uh has
finished installing I can click I'll
just double click on this so you can see
how this this would work if you're
running this at home wanted to follow
along um so here is The Notebook for
today and you can come down we don't
need to run this pip install but we can
come down and run this one right here
and
um it looks like that ran um and yeah it
looks like we're good to go here so I'm
actually not going to use this um I'm
going to run it locally on my machine
but just
um um awesome that you can you can run
that if if you want to and follow
along
okay so I'm going again I'm going to be
talking about pandas 2 polars and duct
EB a little bit about me um a lot of you
might know me um as the author of this
book effective pandas um to to those who
have this book who have read it thank
you I appreciate your support um just
FYI effective pandas 2 is U basically
done it's waiting for a a a a final once
over by Panda core
developer um and um and I'm actually in
the middle of effective pollers so um
that should be fun um so a little bit
about me um why why am I talking about
this so when I graduated from college I
um started working with python doing
data science back in 1999 we were doing
natural agage processing this is before
things like Spacey and nltk existed um
in 2006 I made a python olap engine at a
company and then later I heard about
pandas and a lot of things that pandas
were doing were very similar to what I
was doing and so I I started using
pandas uh professionally uh started uh
uh writing books about it
um and so I wrote a book called learning
the Panda's library in
2016 um did some stuff with spark in
2019 uh wrote the second edition of the
pandas cbook in
2020 um in 2021 uh wrote effective
pandas and when I wrote effective pandas
um at that time I had had been uh
teaching and uh Consulting with pandas
uh for a good chunk of time and I
actually had some pretty strong opinions
about Panda's usage and and what that
should look like and again if you've
read the book you're probably familiar
with a lot of those and I'll I'll kind
of go over some of them in our course
today and then you know last year I did
quite a bit with qdf qdf if you're not
familiar with it is NVIDIA tool probably
the fastest pandas imple uh pandas
implementation also probably the fastest
data frame
implementation uh basically implementing
the Panda's API on on top of gpus um
did a lot with modin was an adviser for
a company called pollers which
basically took the modin technology and
made it so you could run your pandas
code on top of
snowflake um and did some with polers as
well so so that's kind of
um where where my background is uh in
most of my time these days is spent
doing corporate training uh Consulting
um that sort of thing it in I like to
say that I I sell snake oil and teach
people tell lies with data but I go into
big companies and help them Learn Python
and then help them use the python data
stack so to speak so a lot of pandas a
lot of um
visualization a lot of um U things like
actually
boost okay so so pandas 2 for those who
aren't aware came out a while ago and um
you know if you are using pandas uh we
we you just uh say that in the chat so I
I know like who has familiarity with
that also if if you want to just say
like what domain you're using it with um
that would be awesome and maybe if if
you're so motivated you can say like
what your favorite feature of pandas and
maybe the thing that maybe you dislike
most about it as
well um so uh a lot of PE I'm I'm sure
most people know here that python is a
slow language so we're we're at the slow
language conference which is kind of
weird that python is a slow language but
like it's it's also the language that's
most used for data science which like
processing data and so so what's the
deal how how does that even happen and I
I blame this conference on
numpy again probably preaching to the
choir here but basically what numpy does
is numpy gives us a an escape hatch from
the slow language of python basically
encapsulating an array of numbers and
instead of having you know in Python
everything is an object so when you make
an integer you have an integer object
and there's overhead there's like 30
bytes of overhead for that object on top
of that and instead of having that per
uh value overhead what what numai said
is I'll give you overhead but it's going
to be for a block of memory and so as
long you stay in the playground of numpy
you basically get C speeds and a little
bit more greater than C memory usage but
close to C memory usage you don't have
to pay that python
penalty
um awesome so we got people who are
doing Financial modeling very cool 10
years of Pand as well you should
probably be giving this uh Brian
um you know messing with time series
data yeah so pandas has background in
finance so great for time series data um
everything rescue boat operations that's
cool um earth science um replacing Excel
yeah
awesome okay so so basically numpy was
that escape patch um numpy is great for
arrays of data not necessarily great for
tabular data or structur data like we
see in Excel
or uh spreadsheets or SQL so pandas is a
way for us to represent a heterogeneous
data
uh columnar data and and basically
pandas one which I'll generally refer to
as pandas one or Legacy pandas in this
talk
um uh Builds on top of num high so
pandas 2 came out a couple months ago uh
you know there a few new features sort
of the main ones that I think people
should be aware of is uh piie Arrow
replacing as an optional back in for
numpy again stress that this is optional
right now you kind of have to um tell it
that you want to use py arrow and
um uh and then copy on WR so so um what
does py get us at a high level so so I
imagine most of you are familiar with pi
Arrow but basically it's a standardized
in memory representation of tabular data
the idea being that you can say like
here is a p or a blob that represents
some tabular data and then tools that
support the arrow format theoretically
you could say I want to suck this into
this tool and it could do a zero memory
copy sort of thing and just load in that
memory blob and then be able to access
uh that data from another tool um I I
think that's kind of cool for for my use
cases um um not like do I jump shift
from because of an inmemory
representation not not NE necessarily um
but uh what this what this also gives us
is like uh the P Arrow implementation of
this basically has uh a bunch of tooling
to do uh pandas and data frame like
operations and so pandas 2 can leverage
that and because uh this Arrow back this
Arrow specification is basically meant
from the ground up it's built from the
ground up for tabular data can do a a
lot of things much faster so namely what
you get from Arrow for pandas users is
you get better string type so Legacy
pandas because numpy doesn't really have
a string type to stick in an array what
it would do is make an array a column
for your strings be a numpy column that
would be backing that and then and the
values of that would be basically
pointers to python string objects you at
a high level not very much more
efficient than having like a python list
with strings in it that's kind of what
it was except instead of a python list
it was a numpy array with strings in it
and so when you did string operations
you got you know to to to mess with
strings but those were all python
strings and so you had the overhead of
python there uh pyo gives us basically a
a trim down so you'll probably say 50 to
70% memory usage for if you use the pyo
data type for for string and then the
copy on right there is um uh and pandas
too kind of fixed a lot of these copy
issues as well but
um um being just smart about uh when you
do something do you need to copy it or
can you just pass the original object
and then only copy what's changed
basically the idea there so folks who
are doing a lot of chaining probably
important to have this cop on right and
if if you've read my effective pandas
book I'm I'm a pretty big fan of
chaining so again you if if you're
falling along um at home um and you're
using that notebook that I showed you on
GitHub you won't need to do this but um
otherwise you probably want to do
something like this um for for this
purpose for pandas the main thing here
is when you pip install pandas and you
upgrade it you'll get pandas too if you
want to take advantage of pie Arrow you
need to explicitly install Pi arrows of
dependency as
well um again it's an optional backend
for um pandas so I'm going to
um um run this piece of code here this
is basically making a data frame um so
this is uh some f financial data here
like cancel date of some product um when
did it start when did it end
um and and the revenue and the payments
here and um so we're using our friend PD
read
CSV and uh the key part here for pandas
2 is saying D type back into this pie
Arrow so what does that do that's
telling pandas to turn on H pie Arrow as
the engine that that pandas is using
behind the
scenes so um once I've got that
um you know if I look at this this looks
like a pandas data frame however if I
come and inspect this D types here um we
can see that we
have this in 64 Pi Arrow um note that
it's using date time 64 here which to be
pedantic is not a pi arot type there's a
Time NS pyo um that that's
uh the py type
um and then it didn't uh actually uh
wasn't able to to convert this cancel
date here so you you see I I told it to
pars these things but kind of did a best
effort but you know sometimes it it kind
of fell so I'm going to go through
another step here and we're going to
just like force it here so I'm going to
say let's let's convert this to to
datetime here and um we're going to
replace these na strings uh with um
with datetime here so we'll just try and
run that there and that looks like that
works so so on that note um couple
couple other things about P Arrow backet
so one it gives us strings which is
probably the big thing but a lot of uh
people were annoyed that nump didn't
support missing integer values and so
Arrow supports missing data type sort of
from the ground up and so uh you can
have an INT column uh like there could
be missing values in like this rers some
payments here and in this case um they
don't have missing values but if they
did have missing values it could still
be represented as an integer type um so
here I'm going to just uh jump through
some hoops to uh convert this to the
piie arrow um type there and you can see
that this is this is the pi Arrow
type okay um
VF says they're having audio cracking
issues oh that's not good
[Music]
um
whoops it's it's it's it's it's okay for
us so
okay okay generally my Network's pretty
good so
so hopefully it's okay um okay so so
again I I can uh you know change these
uh types two explicit Pi arot types
um and
um so here I might do something like
this where I make this little function
called tweak and um I'm just making a CH
so this is using that chaining that I
was just talking about here uh
where I'm basically saying okay uh I've
got my data frame I'm going to make this
column here then I'm going to convert
this column to this type and then I'm
also going to uh convert these other
columns to the type so this is chain of
operations generally I'll do this uh for
most data sets I come across and uh I I
like to write my pandas code like this
put parentheses around this escape the
new line rules but just write everything
as one method after another uh do you
have to do this no you don't but it
makes your code look like a recipe I
claim that it makes your code easier to
read and use and once you get used to it
um it's going to be very nice for Polar
people um you know uh chaining is is
even more strongly encouraged because uh
when we talk about poers has the ability
to query
optimization on chain query and can do
some cool things with that that pandis
because of its eager can't really do
them okay so so this this is my basic
data set again not particularly
interesting data set it's got like five
rows of data here but I'm going to show
um like a common operation here so says
like suppose we're dealing with a
company that offers a monthly
subscription service customers can
cancel at any time that are build at the
beginning of the month in this scenario
we need cancel calculate the unbilled
receivables at the end of each month uh
revenues that the company has earned but
not build to the to the customer so you
know one of the one of one of my pet
peeves is like these pandas articles
that you'll see on the internet it's
like top 20 things you can do with
pandas and um
and what you'll see is you'll basically
see like this listicle of like do this
method do this method and one of them
they'll tell you about is apply and
they're like apply is cool because you
can pass in a function and you can use
the function so people think that
um uh that okay well I'm just GNA use
apply for everything and you can do that
the problem is is remember python is a
slow language and and sort of the key to
um pandas is that we have this like
numpy or P Arrow layer and then we have
this Panda API on top of that when we're
using apply we're kind of going through
that
layer and that slows things down and so
you know you see people do something
like that like this this is actually
kind of a complicated operation here I
mean I can I've done more complicated
operations but uh you know we're
actually doing a bunch of operations on
a row here and uh this is like normal P
like if you know uh this is um not
missing and the cancel dat is less than
the period um then we're going to return
Nan here if the start date is less than
period and end date is greater than
Period start the revenue is greater than
some of payments then we're going to
return the revenue minus some payments
otherwise we're going to say zero and so
let just run this here and I'm going to
make a new column called unbuild
receivables and we can see that it looks
like that worked at the end here um I
got like a nan up here here and an end
down here and then we've got those
calculations that look like they worked
so you know like I said a lot of these
articles like show this and then I see
people in the wild going off they're
putting a Ply on everything which is
which is quite slow uh whereas what we
really want to do is something like this
um so this is the vectorized version of
this and U you know it's doing some
calculations up here um and then it's
doing another calculation here which is
basically the conversion of the above uh
to this down here here um issue with
this is is that like this uses this wear
which is kind of weird it's kind of like
it's not like an if than else it's it's
more like an else statement but um you
do it on what you want to keep so we're
going to stick in what we want to keep
which is like the If part up here and
then this is like the Els on that so we
kind of have to rejigger our logic and
it makes like writing like I'm fine like
saying things I don't like about pandas
or whatever the wear I think is a little
bit awkward but you know this works
gives us the same result and um you know
people ask you know why why do I care
and so I'm going to do a micro Benchmark
of this and we're we're just going to
Benchmark like the apply version of this
versus um the vectorized version you can
see like the vectorized version is what
200 times faster on my machine doing
this you know the MacBook Pro M1 chip
so you know that that might be
interesting to you I mean this takes you
know 600 milliseconds half a second to
run this takes two
milliseconds I can barely detect 600
milliseconds but you know if if you had
you know you know this is 150,000 lines
of or 100,000 lines if you had you know
a few more million lines of code you can
get up to where this this actually makes
a big difference and and so my general
again people ask me what they should use
use General like benchmarking advice is
use uh what is um fast on your machine
and well and also bench mark on the
sides of data that you're using in
production because a lot of these things
if you change the numbers it changes the
performance and and what I mean by
Numbers if you change the size of the
data change the performance here um I've
got a number implementation of this um
for the sake of time I'm actually going
to just skip this um it it speeds it up
a little bit more but
um
that
um okay yeah and and Angelo says on the
code spaces it's like four milliseconds
versus 1.3 seconds so yeah not quite
sure what's going on with the code
spaces there but um okay so if if You'
got questions about pandas 2 let me know
uh what those are throw those into the
chat
um and then I'll start uh talking about
polars and sort of comparing and
contrasting those but I I just wanted to
to you know give you a kind of overview
of like what what's cool about pandas 2
again from my point of view you got that
Pi Arrow um and piie arrow in itself is
is you know like the idea of passing
around data for for my purposes You Know
sample size one not particularly
interesting per se but uh you know speed
UPS on string operations certainly and
and memory savings for Strings certainly
uh
cool um uh Brian says any backwards
compatibility concerns or gotchas yeah
that's a great question so again at this
point in time Brian um the py back end
is optional you have to enable it so you
can take your legacy pandas code it
should mostly just run uh some things
are a little bit more strict in pandas
to basically like if you're doing an
aggregation and you've got like stream
columns in the aggregation like you're
saying group buy this and then take the
mean it will complain and it will say
like you can't do the mean and so you
you have to like add in a numeric only
is true to say only the mean on the
numeric columns but other other than
that like your your pandas uh Legacy
pandas code should work on pandas too
and some of it should be faster without
even taking advantage of of the P Arrow
data types um and then you're going to
want and put thrown that D type back end
uh that's going to probably if you got a
lot of stream data save you memory and
also incre increas increase your time
there um there um as far as other
gotches there um theoretically like a
lot of things should just work um in
practice um some most things worked I'll
say um maybe are some rough edges like I
said I'm finishing the book effective
pandas 2 and like that has like what I
consider more real world examples rather
than like 20 things you can do listicle
type things where it's like here here's
you know I don't care about 20
individual things I care about here's my
data and I want to clean it up and it's
not just one thing that I do to it but
it's a bunch of things I do to clean it
up or to to analyze it and uh so that
chain you know have a more comp a chain
do those chains work with pandas to uh
for the most part they do there are some
gotas here and there where it's like
um you know we have a pandas 2 uh or Pi
Arrow time in the index and like
exporting that kind of Fells there there
are some weird things i' i' filed a
bunch of bugs with uh the pandas folks
and and a lot of them have been
addressed that's kind of cool that
pandas developers are open to like
fixing those things up
um so yeah at a high level a lot of
things should work there there might be
some gotchas there but um I think you
know if you are a heavy pandage user
this is um
um probably get to try your code out see
if you get like memory savings or speed
improvements from this you you probably
should especially if you're like doing
cop On rideing You' got chaining going
on
there um yeah so Brandon says any
reasons not to use py ARL again there
might be some
regressions again like 90% plus your
code should work but there might be some
sort of corner cases like I said P my
experience is that the pandas developers
have been uh pretty Swift to address
those uh uh things that they want there
not to be issues right but that's kind
of a big change to pull let out and a
lot of people are doing a lot of things
with pandas so so they they might have
not have complete coverage of
that okay uh great questions um sorry
Matt by the way there's another question
in the Q&A section oh awesome yeah let
let me let me address that and then um
um yeah and I don't know how to clear
off the screen or whatnot um but since I
use pandas a lot I wanted to try poers
for lazy evaluation schedule query
Optimizer also native back in but all my
logic relies a lot on pandas index um
how can I migrate to polars or handle
the missing index from Luca okay um
great question
um and
um okay so I'm not sure if my screen is
showing or that question is showing on
there um okay um so look basically like
the indexes there let's talk about polar
let me see if I address your question um
I'll say this at a high level uh Luca
um it's easy to go uh from pandas to PO
them back if you're using pi ar2
theoretically you should get that zero
copy in there so if you've got things
that are index based um you can do those
in in pandas and then uh stick them into
poers uh where you want um so so um it
it might I might it might help me if you
like tell me like what specific
speically you're using the index 4 and
then I can po possibly give you a better
answer and you can put that in the chat
if you want LCA okay so let let's talk
about polers uh the the polers library
if I can find my mouse okay there it is
um so uh the the creator of pandas wrote
a blog post many years ago about like
things they hate about pandas and um I'm
going to contrast this with with you
know what the creator of polar said so
Richie been the Creator poers I heard
him talk uh in a recent talk and he
described polers as I think he described
it as like a query
engine with a data frame API on top of
it it also has a SQL API on top which I
I think fundamentally is different than
like Legacy pan P pandas even pandas 2
where I think pandas 2 you can describe
that as has a data frame API um does it
have a query engine not really it's
basically like an eager engine so say
like we're representing this data and
when you do something we do the
operation uh whereas poers is basically
saying uh you know we've got 50 years of
database research and things like query
optimization predicate push down things
like that and and if you squint at this
these operations that we are doing to
data frames are basically the same
operations that people have been doing
two databases for many years so why
wouldn't you leverage that technology
and and so again there's a sort of 10
Things I Hate About pandas and Rich
claims that Polaris has addressed all 10
of those things that you know those
those drawbacks of pandas I I I kind of
view it as like you know pandas again
was written like here's things I want to
do to data here's an API that lets me do
that and and so we'll do do that um
coming back at that uh you know you
could
think maybe re-engineer that from the
ground up and and do things a little
better so this also leverages Arrow um
it does not use Pi Arrow it uses a rust
implementation of
Arrow
um so that's one thing to be aware of is
just like um where pandas is sort of
we've got does with basically numpy or
py under the covers here this is
basically rust under the covers um and
most of the implementation of um poers
is in R there's a
a python basically wrapper around that
but as you'll see when I show you this p
uh python wrapper there's nothing really
pythonic about it and you could imagine
that this wrapper could be adapted to
any language um basically because it's
not really using features of python for
better for worse
um and uh whereas a lot of libraries
have said like we're going to adapt the
pandas API and kind of take the pandas
API because for better for worse pandas
is the tool that people are using in
data science and the API is kind of the
API of tabular data science uh polar is
sort of thrown that out we're said okay
the API as is has some of these issues
and so we're going to throw out the API
and so polers is is pretty different
than than pandas U and so it has this
notion of expressions and context so you
can think of expression as
representing a column or operations on
column or columns and then the context
is where you do those operations right
where you can have here's an operation
that does a filter and if I do a select
with that it selects um uh The Columns
as as booleans right but if I do a
filter with that it Returns the rows
where the booleans are true sort of
thing I'll show some examples of these
Expressions um but again the API is
completely different so people who are
saying like can I use polar instead of
pandas um yeah you can but you've got to
Port the code it's it's not it's not
like Qi or Spark spark is implementing
the Panda's API or even mode in where
it's like we're going to aim to
implement Panda's bugs as well because
we want to 100% API coverage there
that's not not the case at all uh
pullers does have lazy
evaluation so it can run in a lazy mode
it also by default will run in an eager
Mo well depending on how you create a
data frame so so there is a a notion of
a data frame there's a class called Data
frame there's that's a class called
series as well just turns out that we
basically never use Series in polar we
only use data frame or a lazy data frame
you can create a lazy data frame as
well and that lazy data frame is kind of
one of the key um value ads or pullers
um so another way I think of a data
frame is like an eager uh materialized
piece of data right it's got all the
data in there where a a lazy data frame
is it it logically represents data but
it doesn't have rows and columns as is
it's a a directed as graph of like
operations to do with a logical
representation of data and then when you
tell it to materialize or execute it's
going to go through this graph of
operations and and do some optim query
optimization and then execute that and
give you the data at that point and um
because it's written in poers and it's
smart from the ground up and and knows
how to do things like max out your
course uh you know like this is
described as a query engine it
has uh basically worker cues for every
thread and it can do smart things where
it's like okay we're into this group ey
operation and we can parallelize that
pretty easily so we're going to throw on
for each CPU uh it has a worker Q we're
going to throw on these operations to
these cues and we're just GNA let them
run through and if one Q uh you know
finishes we can move operations from the
other ones to max out those CPU like
that's that's the query engine side of
it which which pandas doesn't really
have at all right and so that that's
kind of one of one of the big
differences there um and again you know
people said you know can will you know
with python like dropping the Gill in in
the future or like these sub
interpreters can can python kind of do
that with pandas um I mean it can to
some extent but you're you're using
python to manage those threads whereas
this is all done and rust and so um you
don't have that overhead at all you you
basically have fast times for doing
that okay so so I'm GNA actually go back
to my same example here
um uh let's see there's a question here
from ad does po run distributed fashion
can run so okay so that's that's a great
question probably let me address that at
the end uh with a table basically no it
doesn't it's not distributed um and and
when I summarize I'll kind of go over
that a
um okay so so let's load our data here
this I mean this looks actually like
pandas like it's not the pandas but I
mean this looks like pandas here uh in
sort of uh pandas we have the PO library
and we're saying read CSV and if you
look at this this look like data frame
this is this is actually eager right
this is just a normal data frame um
couple things to note like it shows you
the type here um so these are these
these Arrow strings here but there is no
index on the leftand side so one of the
things that uh uh uh the poers folks
thought is
like you don't really need an index and
and I know a lot of people use an index
for various things but poers is like you
know we've been using databases I mean
databases do have an index but they're
fundamentally different than than the
notion of a um a panda's index and and
so like you can think of a panda index
not as a database index but like a row
label right you need a row label and and
poers says no you don't need a row label
um you know if you want a r label you
can make a column that has that
information in it so again there was a
question there um know how do I get
around that um yeah so again if you kind
of give me some insight into like what
you're using the index 4 I can probably
help answer that question a little bit
better um
Luca let me know okay so you know the
you know as I as I just ran into like
the API is different there there is some
some uh API uh consistency um so let me
so for example we can ask like what the
D types are right and this looks
different from what You' get in pandas
and in pandas You' get back a series um
generally we don't see series very often
in in polar length Okay um me see that
these are utf8 they're not uh string or
dates so if we want to convert these to
dates um I'm going to convert them and
this is how I do that and this this
looks completely different from pandas
uh so we have this width columns this is
a context and then inside of width
columns we run these Expressions you can
think of withd columns as like the
assign method in pandas here but
basically I'm saying okay let's let's uh
represent a a column or series of
columns or or group of columns and so we
use this this PL call to create an
expression so here I'm saying here's a
bunch of columns here and then these um
uh the expression engine has an
attribute called Str strr kind of like
pandas and then say like we can parse a
date time and convert to a date and this
is the format of that and so when we do
that this is in eager mode so it just
executes you can see that these are
converted into dates now like
that um so so interesting thing to note
is like this says null here um so one of
the things that's a little bit different
and maybe confusing in in polers is that
polar has um both null and na which
might be confusing for some pandas users
because pandas has like is null and is
na which are synonyms I kind of wish
pandas didn't have is null at all
because nowhere in pandas do we refer to
null things polar does have n and
they're different from na so in in
polar's land um Na is like a floating
point that you did some calculation like
0 divid by zero uh for for like nump is
na um that is that is an a in in Po and
then null means that there's no answer
there so so there's a difference between
those and there's like operations is na
a and is no which is a little bit
different um so I'm going to show that
same uh operation that we did with like
the apply uh we're going to do that in
uh polar here so this is the polar
version of that and polar you know it
doesn't have an if then else but it has
basically the same thing you can say
when and then and otherwise here and I
can chain these together so I I I really
wish that Panda's had some syntax like
this it it doesn't um you know there's a
a bug to to to kind of or feature
request to do that but they haven't done
that so
far but I can kind of read this as like
when this is the case here um and note
that um uh I'm not passing in the data
frame here and I'm just saying PL column
um I'm saying there is some logical
thing that's a column and the name of it
is cancel date but this is not pointing
to the data at all this is just saying
that this this is a column call this
expressions and we build up these
operations on these expressions and then
we tell the query engine to go like
figure out how to tie that expression to
the actual data and run this so like
here you know when this is true then we
want none as a result when this is true
then we want Revenue minus sum of
payments otherwise we want zero and
otherwise you want none there and then
down here we're going to say um you know
this is what I did to convert my columns
and I'm gonna say with columns again
again you can think of with columns as
an assign and I'm going to just call
this function here and make a new column
from that now you might think like why
do I need uh can if you look at the
documentation for with columns you can
throw in multiple things things into
with column so you can have multiple
Expressions here um this is just one
expression but you could have multiple
Expressions why can't I do this in this
in the same expression and the issue is
is that remember uh this query engine is
going to try and Max things out and when
you have with columns it's going to say
I'm going to create all these columns at
the same time and so because this uh
calc unbuild uh depends on these being
actual dates and not uh strings there uh
we need to basically Al have like a
mutex so to speak or like this needs to
execute before we run this next uh
column creation there and we can't stick
that expression in the same location for
that but if you look at this you know we
get the same results we get out there so
I'm going to just make uh not that I can
convert from pandas really easy I just
say from pandas here and then I'm going
to do my uh time it here and run this
here so interesting to note like this
takes five on my machine 5.7
milliseconds and I think I think we were
at like four up here
um two so so this is actually
slower um on Polar than it is in pandas
I'm not quite sure why that is
um uh but um yeah you know you you see a
lot of things like polar as fast and and
polar um it's not that polers is slow um
polers is fast it's a more intelligent
um query engine and can run things on
multiple cores but in this case uh it it
wasn't and and uh one of the uh Panda's
core developers
um uh wrote a blog post uh you know kind
of ranting on some of these benchmarks
that you see or benchmarks you see like
p po is like five to 10x faster on
standard benchmarks
and than pandas and they went through
the code like oh well you know these
people are kind of doing things in a
dumb way with pandas and if you speed
them up then you
basically get things that are same order
of magnitude um as Polar now generally
polers is faster than them um where
where polar kind of really shines is
Group by operations right when you're
doing a group by that can happen on
multiple cores and uh pendas really
isn't smart about doing that uh
and so that that's kind of where where
polar speeds
up so so the Lucas Point um yeah um you
know can we can we take advantage of
polar speed um yeah you can you can
convert uh because they're both using
Arrow as a back end uh you can get these
kind of copy free conversions from one
to another and you could you could do um
your
operations in polar where where pandas
is slow um and then push it back into
pandas as needed if you need to do index
operations there
um but um Luca where you're going to get
the the biggest speedups is is things
like group by um uh but but you can so
we I haven't really gone over laziness
here so so let me give an example of
being lazy here so I'm just going to
write this out to disk here and uh here
I've got basically my same tweak so this
tweak function is what I had up above
not that I I follow that same thing in
like pandas M po I'm going to make a
little function to clean this up um
instead of doing re CSV I'm going to do
the scan CSV and scan CSV does not
return an eager materialized data frame
it returns a lazy data frame here so
when I run this here and this is the
same code um this runs but instead of
giving me results here it gives me this
query plan right and you can see what
this is this is doing this is not
particularly interesting because it's
not doing too much but you could imagine
um you know where you have maybe a
filter and you select different columns
and maybe you do some group buy or
something like that
um this is not even you know at this
point when I run this this not even
loaded the file the the CSV file it's
just a this this is what I would do um
you know if you got various filters and
and selects and
it's smart enough that it can know that
like when I read this CSV file I only
need to read these rows and I only need
to read these columns right so based on
these operations you do things like
predicate push down and other
operations um and you get that
specifically because there's a query
engine on the back end and because it's
lazy and because you're chainy right so
you're chaining these operations
together and um it can do the query
optimization on all those OP operations
uh whereas pandas you know you can chain
uh does that give you optimization no
you kind of have to manually do that
like our our core developer friended
when they looked at those benchmarks but
you know if you're smart about how penas
is doing things um for a lot of things
you can be very close to uh polar
speed okay so yeah um so so the question
does polers run distributed fashion
poers does not run in distributed
fashion so I I say pandas um pandas uh
the library I cont that versus Pand the
API because there are things that scale
out panda is the API to distribute your
fashion things like modin or dask like
that company I work for Ponder would
take the API and let you run the API on
things like uh big querer or snowflake
right um so so pan API has kind of the
answer from small data to um medium or
large data where my definition is small
data not to get you know into the weeds
is small data is data that fits in into
RAM medium data Maybe doesn't fit into
RAM it fits on a single machine big data
doesn't fit on a single machine Panda's
kind to has the answer or solution for
all of those uh scenarios whereas poers
um has the small data and it does have
some spill over you can have some
streaming functionality where you can
stream from disk and so you could
imagine um you've got sort of the small
and medium data but you don't really
have the big data answer there now there
is a company behind Po and I imagine
Richie is probably working on something
to do that but uh you know as is right
now when you're working with polers
you're working with small or medium
data okay
um um Matt there's another question
another question here I will show on
screen now yeah I got it there Nishan
thanks um is there an advantage using
polar over P spark so far polar is
looking very similar to py Spark engine
lazy valve Etc okay so so great question
Nishan um I mean we can probably push
that question off to our our duct EB
part as well um but but yeah I'll kind
of answer it here um so again pipar
uh kind of you know can you run pisar on
a single node yeah you can um it's not
going to be as efficient as polers
so I'm actually going to answer this in
the context of of duct b instead of of
um polers here but you you can sort of
adapt that uh so so long story short
ducky B actually um has implemented a py
spark interface on top of duct
DP
that might seem kind of weird but their
thesis is like a lot of people jump the
gun on like going to Big Data like oh we
need Hadoop back in the Big Data days
and then spark came out it's like we
need to use spark because that's what
the cool people are doing and it turns
out that a lot of people have data that
fits in into a single machine or you can
rent a big single machine on the cloud
and you can fit data onto a single
machine and not have to worry about this
distributed problem and and slowing
things down running over Network and so
like the duck DB folks they have this
thesis that you know a lot of people are
running spark and they don't need to but
there's a lot of overhead there's a lot
of code in that wouldn't it be nice if
you could like take your spark code and
just run it on a single machine but run
it fast and so they have a they're
they're kind of doing like the reverse
of like the modin and like that Ponder
where that was taking the Panda's API
and putting to Big Data they're taking
this big data API and putting it to like
small data um and they had an experiment
I think where um
uh they ran their code and uh
benchmarked it on on their polers again
caveat benchmarks whatever but anyway
they they had a benchmark where they run
their spark uh query on pollers and to
replicate that on a cluster uh they
needed 30 machines to replicate the
Speed and Performance they got at a
single machine there um so again just
sort of demonstrating that you know if
you can keep your things uh if use small
data or medium data and and uh duck also
has intelligent spill over to to dis so
it does when call medium data um there's
some pretty big performance gains that
you get from not having to manage a
cluster that infrastructure and cost and
um being able to just run things quicker
clip and so I I think that same thing
sort of applies to polers um as well
like you know if you can run poers code
on a single machine but polar again the
API is different than that um and and
interesting that um
spark um actually has a a pandas API for
compatibility where where they're kind
of going to that pandas API uh layer uh
which
again pandas isn't really built for
laziness I I kind of hope that they get
there but you know I don't I'm not sure
that that that they ever will
necessarily get to that lazy query
engine side okay great questions um uh
Paulo says what's the advantages of
poers versus
Daft um I'm not familiar with Daft
um yeah um
so it looks like Daft is some other um
data frame engine you know I feel like I
know a lot of these database engines but
um I'm
not
um I'm just searching for it here get
Daft okay um yeah I I I'm not familiar
with Daft so I I can't really comment on
on that I'll have to I'll have to check
that out thanks for thanks for the
question
there okay um you think that someone who
makes their money telling people about
data frames would would know that
okay um so the for the final portion
here I want to talk about duck which
might seem kind of weird like why talk
about like a database when we're talking
about data frames and tabular
data and again if you sort of think
about like what I just said about polars
in the polers is um a a query engine
with a data frame API on top of it well
a query engine the database is a query
engine and I would say that one of the
most Advanced Analytical query engines
right now is actually duct
DB um so so duct DB for those who aren't
familiar with it is you can sort of
think of it as instead of SQL light
which is an in process transactional
database this is an inprocess olap or
analytical column or database so so it's
basically like you can you can run uh uh
SQL in process like why would I want to
do that well basically you know if you
can represent you know these tabular
operations uh in SQL you can run them in
SQL and a lot of people have been using
SQL for doing tabular manipulation and
quering uh for many years so uh it turns
out that yeah there's there's a powerful
Engine with years of research and and
work behind it and
um It's relatively easy to use and um
actually poers has a SQL API that it
ships with so polar is kind of kind of
like it can be like SQL is and and duck
like I said um duck actually has a spark
API on top of that as well so you have
sort of this crossover where people you
know a lot of people who are doing data
frame things are like we like data frame
syntax but a lot of people like SQL so
you know can we get the best of both
worlds um so a little bit about the
background here a C++ implementation
it's a single binary you don't have to
install a lot of dependencies like in
Python you just say pip install duct DB
and you don't have to start up a server
and do the connection you just sort of
get it for free which is kind of nice um
and then the other thing is that if you
look at like these operations like uh if
I go through like my effective pandas
book there's a lot of like group buys
and melts and pivots and and things like
that which traditionally have been
painful uh for people to sequel how do I
know that because like I said in my
history like back around 2006 I wrote
like a olap engine on top of a like monb
which I I'm a I'm a contributor to SQL
Alchemy because I wrote the back end for
monb which is kind of I would say like
the the spiritual lineage sort of for
duck TB uh way back when and and doing a
lot of these operations that are kind of
trivial uh in data frames are kind of a
pain traditionally in uh SQL and duct DB
has an extended SQL syntax that makes
things you know like window functions
and um pivoting uh really easy to do so
you can basically do your operations
that you would do with pandas or polar
in duct Deb but you have I would say a
query engine that that's probably faster
and more optimized than than the polar's
quty engine the other thing is like
polar um you know until recently you
know had had a few developers working on
it whereas dctb had a lot of developers
and dctb got I don't know some absurd
amount of funding which um may or may
not be good depending on like your view
of VC or whatnot but there's a lot of
investment into improving uh DB I would
say more so than probably both pandas
and poers combined uh Manpower behind
the scenes working on duct DB
so um which is kind of cool um okay so
uh for our purposes you can pip install
duck DB I'm also because I'm in Jupiter
I'm going to use this jupy SQL plugin
which is kind of nice here so I'm just
going to configure that um and we'll
just import dub and then once I have
this two SQL I can say like I want to
connect to like like I do a SQL light I
say and memory duct EB we'll just say
select 42 with that line magic there and
this gives me it looks like a data frame
um and that's because you see I have
this Auto pandas that just converts the
result to a pandas data frame here I can
do a cell magic in addition to a line
magic here and I can also like say uh
throw that into a variable so here's my
DF variable here uh for from running my
query okay so let's let's do something a
little bit more involved here um I'm
going to say okay drop this table if it
exists the bill table and then uh let's
do this read CSV Auto right so there are
a bunch of functions that dctb has given
us that allow us um
to to uh do operations that um uh
traditionally are are more of a pain
um uh than they would
be
uh okay so yeah let's run this read CSV
and uh the result is a data frame that
says success okay uh so at this point
there should be a data frame called Bill
Let's just query that I'm going to say
select star from Bill limit five and
there we go look at this this looks like
a Pand data frame again that's because
it's spitting the results out in pandas
but um this this is our data our friend
that we we just looked at now you might
want to make sure that like this I mean
this this actually says Nat which is not
a time so so you know we might be okay
there and we could inspect like the
pandas D types of this and capture it as
pandas here but we kind of want to look
at what's going on with the database
here so it turns out that like there's
an information schema table so duck
Foods itself or eats its own dog food I
guess um a lot of databases use
databases to to implement the databases
right so so the metadata is stored in
the database here and so there is a uh
tables column this kind of interesting
um there's actually an extended sequence
or a sequel syntax here um if you want
to say select star from a table you can
just say from table you don't have say
select star which is kind of nice and
you can put like Wares on this or
whatever so this is just saying like
select star from this and it says like
we have a table called Bill okay so
that's that table I just loaded and
there's another table called columns so
I'll just say from columns here and we
can see that um okay here are our
columns those look like they're good and
here's the types and the types are dates
so so this is actually kind of uh nice
in that like uh um Po and pandas kind of
struggled uh with those dates somewhat
uh more or less and and uh duct B just
sort of s them up and didn't really have
too much problems
here um and Dominique says you know what
what exactly do you mean by mediumsized
data sets Okay so here here's my very
basic uh description Dominique uh small
data fits into RAM on a single
machine uh medium data is larger than
Ram but would fit onto dis on a single
machine and then big data does doesn't
fit onto that okay so Dominique uh tools
like polers and duck have intelligent
spillover to dis hence support for
medium data but um poers or duct DB
don't really have the scale out in the
Big Data like a cluster of of duct DB or
cluster of pullers if that makes sense
domic let me know if that answers your
question
um okay so so let's do our complicated
query uh W which was like our rece
unbuild receivables here and we can do
this with our our friend case uh
statement here and this
actually I mean looks uh pretty readable
compared to like the pandas uh like
where you know this is just like when
this isn't if like when this is true um
return this um otherwise
um return zero and otherwise return
return null here and let's run that and
there's our unbuilt receivables this is
running on our our 100,000 rows in there
and it looks like it's doing the right
thing
there okay um so this does have Arrow
integration one of the cool things about
dctb is there there's a ton of features
um you can so duct DB in addition to
being like a query engine it actually um
can suck in different things to query
against so it knows how to query
directly against polar or pandas so you
don't you don't even have to copy it in
there it can use its query logic to
query those directly which is kind of
cool but we also have some Arrow
integration in here as well so here I'm
going to read our uh Bild data into a
polar's data frame and look at this I'm
just going to say uh let's read that uh
from our data frame here so instead of
quering
from that polar connection that we made
I'm going to or sorry the WB connection
that we made I'm going to read from this
polar data frame uh so select star um
and then note here I'm saying peel at
the end uh this just converts the result
to a polar's data frame just for fun I'm
gonna actually get rid of the select
star because I think I don't need it
yeah we can just say from Bill right so
we can um
convert from we can take polers into uh
duck DB and we can also get polar out of
that um uh let's uh just capture the
result here and uh convert it to pandas
as
well and uh here we we can just say DF
at the end and we can convert to
pandas um Addie says uh where can I get
a copy of the the the temp bill um I I
did that up here um at a um you just
need to run the cell um let me find it
for you um it
is uh this right here lazy inquery
optimization so this is in the polar
section if you if you run this here it
will it will write that temp directory
that temp file for you
a
okay
okay so so
um so that's kind of cool like you you
at this point you know if you have your
data in polers or pandas you and people
like to use SQL they can write SQL
directly against that um if we need to
like stick this back into pandas uh to
view this so so one the things that like
neither poers nor duct EB does but like
pandas does is pandas has visualization
right pandas has integration with map
plot Lo and which I think is awesome I
actually prefer to plot using pandas
create map plot plots using pandas uh
rather than using map plot directly
because I think the interface from
pandas is actually uh easier and more
intuitive and often I have my data in
Panda data frames already so why
not so I I found like bugs and code from
visualization so I think visualization
is awesome um polar and duct EB don't
have visualization right so if I want to
visualize something
um uh you know we can we can stick it
into pandas uh with one line of code
right DF and then we can use our pandas
do plot to do a plot uh from pandas uh
very
easily okay so so that is is my uh duct
B um
again duct Deb also has that spark
interface so I think this is this is
going to be an interesting space to
watch what we've got is we've got sort
of uh pandas which is the linga franka
and kind of say I'm gonna sort of
spitball or you you
know this this is kind of looking like
that no one got fired for buying IBM
from from a few years ago or sort of
like um were pan is is sort of like this
is established technology that a lot of
people are using you know there are
companies that have millions of lines of
Panda's code uh they can't really
directly go to poers um or duct DB
without doing some engineering right to
to rewrite that and and generally people
don't like to rewrite things just to
rewrite them if they're working right
generally that's not an effective use of
engineering resources we want to create
new things and and better things and a
things are kind of working using an old
technology or whatnot um again just
leave it be and let it let it run so so
um I I don't see folks like migrating to
polers um just for fun uh you know
there's got to be a compelling use case
there also another thing just to just to
realize is that like pandas has had like
a 1.0 release and pullers like um
pullers the Cadence of releases of
pullers is generally on the order of
like or two a month right and and I have
had cases where like my polar code has
broken and and the API has changed right
so so there hasn't been a 1.0 release of
polers um not that I think like there's
gonna be huge breaking changes there but
but it's like this thing this thing is
moving pretty fast right um pandas
releases are kind
of um every now and then there'll be a
release but it's it's not it's not um
you know the Cadence or clip that that
pull going it's not to say that Panda's
developers aren't responsive certainly
they are like I said I've I've for my
effective pandas 2 filed multiple bugs
and most of them have been addressed
very very swiftly by them so you know if
you do have issues with that highly
recommend doing your good turn as as an
open source uh user and and filing those
bugs there um let's see uh agile says Uh
there's some API weirdness with pandas
pyro I think due to incomplete uh
implementation uh the DT excess or and
Pyro having durations rather than time
Deltas hopefully that situation will
reprove yeah um yeah there are yeah some
some of these things uh were were pyaro
it is a little rough um so um and yeah
again uh uh my advice there Giles is um
you know open up those those lines of
communication with the pandas core
developers
um uh you know it if you need to I mean
it is certainly possible to mix and
match right you can have a a panda data
frame that has some py columns and it
has nump columns as well and you can use
both of those um so you know if the pyo
data isn't working for you um you can do
the the the numpy
stuff and um should be relatively good
depending on what you're trying to do um
like the date stuff from from numpy it
is going to be pretty fast and optimized
so I don't think you're going to lose
performance necessarily there where
where the pain might be is is like you
know if if you are one of those folks
who needs to move the data into
something else right uh like you need to
move polar or duct EB
um that might be a little bit more
tricky or you might have some actual
copy to do if it's a numpy instead of P
Aro under the
scenes
um Angelo says probably tangential but
any advice on how you deal with uh read
variables as strings and duct EB um I
need to mass rename a variable my
language server cannot take care of but
uh but not when dealing with variables
in
strings
um yeah so so I think what you're asking
Angelo
is
um that you have I like
like to read variables as
strings I need to mass rename a
variable yeah I guess I'm I'm not I'm
not really parsing parsing what your
issue is Angels maybe if you could
describe it differently I might be able
to help
um
uh GMA says as a beginner it seems like
there are a lot of ways to do similar
things for small and medium data sets is
best to start with one and learn it well
and if so are there any that you would
recommend at least initially um okay so
so that's a great question I'm gonna I'm
gonna scroll up a little bit I've got
this little chart that I made here and
um this you know I made this as an
attempt to to like um uh hopefully be
useful here
um so so what we've got in this chart at
the bottom we have scale um from small
to medium to big and then on the left
hand side we have API and thinking about
this it should be a little bit different
this blue box represents the Panda's API
not the Panda's language spark is this
pink one and then SQL is this orange one
at the bottom again because spark
actually implements some of the Panda's
API um there should be some overlap here
between the pink and the blue here but
you see like pandas qie modin and death
sort of goes outside the box a little
bit like qy Moda name for like 100% API
compatibility their um desk has some
features that are different because it
does have some laziness in it um you see
that pandas and qy are are small data or
qy needs to run on your GPU um modin
actually will run on small data but
because it has some overhead because it
it has things for like scaling out data
uh for really small data that overhead
of like doing the scale out actually
slows mod and down relative to pandas
but like when you start doing a bunch of
group buys and modin sees improvements
over pandas so depending on your
workload on small data modin might be an
improvement whereas desk is is like uh
yeah you you can do dask on smaller data
but you're probably going to want to
push dask onto like big data um so from
spark here my face is kind of covering
it but you've got um
uh like spark is sort of big data in SQL
you can do SQL spark but you can also do
the spark API which actually has some
pandas uh for Big Data there uh big
query ask Google's uh big SQL um
actually recently announced that they're
having a pandas API as well so um you
can kind of see that uh coming up here
like you
can run your pandas code on big query
with that um
and then snowflake
um uh like snowflake has like polar or
Ponder I mean they bought the company
Ponder which is basically running uh
pandas on top of that well snowflake
hasn't officially released that so I
don't I I don't speak for them and I'm
not sure exactly what their plans are
but the technology exists uh to like run
pandas on top of snowflake as well and
then uh you know polar does have SQL
right and poers works for small and
medium data and then polers has its own
API right so it's not spark API it's not
the pan API it's its own API as well and
then duck duck has SQL it's great at SQL
has spark API duck actually has another
API which it calls the relational API uh
which
is again not pandas nor um polers but
it's another API as well so so those I
think those are two um axes of looking
at this data right are those the other
only axes I mean other things you might
want to look at it's like sort of
longetivity of product or how
established it is or if you have
commercial support for those those might
be questions that you want to ask or
even like developers right you know the
question of like um you know if I'm
learning something as like MMA said as a
beginner what do I want to learn and you
know I
think uh right now probably you know if
if I'm giving advice as to like you know
I want to break into the market or
something I think pandas is going to be
you're going to want to learn pandas to
start off with just because there GNA be
a lot more opportunities with pandas um
probably should have some SQL as well um
so so that that would be where where I
would start off with um David says well
your effective Pand is tubu use the same
data sets as the original Edition or are
they all new
examples
um yeah so David effective pandas 2 um
does have some new uh chapters but for
the most part it's it's taking the
existing code and uh running it in in
pandas 2 which has some frozen counts
right so if if you got pandas one um or
you got affected pandas one uh some of
the content will be similar but um I've
had to go through every piece of code
and and make sure that it works with
with with py as back right um so I I
think you know for for those who are
heavy pandas users and like here's what
the the the pandas one code Legacy
pandas code look like and here's what it
looks like with pandas 2 uh I think
that's actually useful for professional
pandage users who are looking to Port
their code and then it has additional
chapters on uh testing and debugging
facturing interrupt
um um I just wanted to give you a heads
up that you have about five minutes
remaining foration thank you okay thank
you yeah so you're going to kick me off
in five minutes here so um you got five
minutes left to to ask questions that
you might have folks um okay Angela says
um sorry I meant is in the following
duct TB from Bill P limit Bill P's polar
or panas variable but it's encased in a
string so you lose semantic
representation of it as a variable
okay
um you need to mass rename a
variable
oh so you need to do like some search
replace
um yeah I mean and you're saying like
your your whatever your language server
on VSS code when you uh rename that
variable doesn't rename the SQL query
um or yeah
so
yeah yeah I mean it is what it is
um I guess if you're concerned about
that you know you can do something where
like before you do your duct DB query
you could just make some like the duct
DB uh data frame and point it to that
variable and then always run your duct B
query from like not the variable but the
new one that you just created the line
before and then you you could sort of be
consistent and get the refactoring there
if that makes sense where you're
extracting the variable Name by just
making another Alias to it don't know if
that helps or not
Angelo
okay
um okay yeah let let me know what other
questions you have um you know F folks
you say like like which which should I
use right which of these Technologies
should I use and and the answer is an
unsatisfying like it depends right
you've got a million lines at pandas
um probably if you're in that world it's
not going to make sense to to migrate to
another system
right so you know you probably want to
stay in pandas land right you're an
established big company you're looking
to hire a bunch of developers um
poers might not be an option there right
because there probably not a lot of
poers developers a SQL might be an
option um there might be a lot of SQL
people pandas might be an option as well
right you're a small startup you want to
do things quickly um and you want to
have things that you know run fast fers
might be an option there right um or or
maybe you say like I want to use duck
and and then I can you know use spark if
I need to scale out to that or you know
you could say well I'm going to run it
on qpy qy is going to be faster than
duck or uh spark um or polar and so
we're GNA we're stick with a panda's API
right and use qy to to get really fast
speed UPS there um so I I didn't
demonstrate qy here but again that's
nvidia's uh basically Panda API and and
running that Panda's code on top that
you know if if you're doing like a
string rename um that's going to be a
slow operation like to rename string
columns or do Replacements on that on on
on a CPU on a GPU if you got 600
cores and each of those 600 cores can
can do uh change a different name and so
it can run 600 times faster on the on
the
GPU okay thanks everyone so much again
um you can follow me on social media I'm
on LinkedIn I'm on Twitter uh if if your
team needs training with pandas or
polers or duck please reach out Matt at
metake again effective pandas 2 coming
out soon effective pollers in the works
as well thanks so much for your
questions have a great rest of your
conference thanks for letting me be on
here U my pleasure yeah thanks everyone